euh parce que nous sommes un casting d'ensemble et
il y a tellement de personnages que je pense
qu'il y a beaucoup de profondeur où ils pourraient
aller avec
Amy les filles et je plaisante en disant que nous allons
aller aux championnats
intergalactiques avec moi comme des extraterrestres en vers
ah qui  Je ne pense pas que ce sera
le scénario mais je ne sais pas qu'il y a une
grosse histoire d'origine d'Amy qui pourrait être
vraiment drôle en Australie euh mais
qui sait qu'il y a tellement de façons qui
pourraient aller et je suppose qu'ils ont parlé à Kay
canon qui a écrit les deux premiers films
et voyez ce qu'elle pense que
les cloches sont de retour